Chicago investigators are looking for a
motive this morning in the deadly
shooting of a criminal court judge a
gunman killed judge Raymond miles
outside his home a woman was also shot
and taken to the hospital in serious
condition
dean reynolds is at the chicago police
headquarters where detectives are
working to learn more about the killer
dean good morning good morning well the
police are going over surveillance video
now looking for clues that might lead
them to a shooter so far though they see
no connection between the gunman in this
case and his victims police were called
to the Chicago home of Circuit Court
Judge Raymond miles around five o'clock
Monday morning according to
investigators an unknown suspect shot a
female friend of miles outside his house
miles and the unidentified woman often
exercised together in the morning after
hearing the commotion miles went to
investigate and came face-to-face with
the gunman who shot him four times they
exchanged words with the offender before
he was fatally shot multiple times at
this time it does not appear that
property was stolen from their person or
the residence the 66 year old's law
career spanned four decades in 2009 he
reportedly ordered William Balfour the
man who killed three members of singer
Jennifer Hudson's family to be held
without bond
miles houses on Chicago's South Side an
area that's become increasingly violent
over the last five years the judge had
security cameras installed at his home I
feel scared because I've been living
over here for ten years and I see the
neighborhood has changing you got a lot
of break-ins burglaries going on
distraught neighbors said they heard
gunfire then a woman's voice screaming
don't kill him don't kill him the judge
died soon thereafter his friend is
expected to survive
you have our word that we will not let
judge Myles life be lost in vain and we
will hold his killer accountable now
according to the surviving victim the
gunman fled on foot but may have had a
car nearby the FBI
is now offering a $25,000 reward for
information leading to a solution of
this crime
Nora alright Dean thank you so much